AHEAD AND CALL THIS.
SPECIAL MEETING OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE TO ORDER ON MONDAY
JUNE SEVENTEENTH.
ON'T MA'AM SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL SENATORS BATES.
BATES HERE MINING MINING HERE
ROB.
ROUGH HERE WELCOME PRESIDENT
WILL CARE ATKINS HERE ATKINS
HERE.
THANK YOU ARE ON THE AGENDA
TODAY -- ARE STANDING COMMITTEE
APPOINTMENTS ITEMS ONE THROUGH.
EIGHT I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON ALL OF MY
SOMEONE WANTS TO SEPARATE SO
MOVES.
OKAY.
THROUGH EIGHT OR SO WHAT WHAT I
WAS I WILL I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
EMOTIONAL ONE THROUGH. EIGHT
NINE TEN AND ELEVEN ON
RECOGNIZING THAT ITEM NINE IS
THE JOINT COMMITTEE APPOINTMENTS.
ITEMS TEN ELEVEN ARE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE RATIFICATIONS.
AND THAT IS IT.
WOULD SOMEONE BE WILLING TO DO
THE MOTION ON THAT.
THANK YOU.
MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS BATES AYE BATES AYE
MONNING.
MONNING AYE ROTH ROTH AYE WILK.
WILK AYE ATKINS HI I CAN SIGN
THAT IS UNANIMOUS COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I AM WITH THAT WE ARE ADJOURNED